All right.
Hi, everybody.
As you've been informed, Eric
Koleda, member of the
Developer Team here on
the AdWords API.
Today, I'm going to be talking
about the MutateJobService.
So most of the AdWords API
that you use today is
synchronous.
You make the request with your
operations, and then you get
back a response with the result
of those operations.
So you're waiting for the
operations to complete.
With asynchronous processing,
the difference here is that
we're kind of decoupling
that relationship.
So you make requests to pass
operations to the server.
The server processes those
operations offline, and not
while you're waiting.
And then you later check back
in to make sure the work is
complete and retrieve
the results.
We're seeing a definitely
increasing demand from our
customers for bulk changes.
Lots of operations.
Very large accounts or
long tail keywords.
The other thing, which I'm sure
almost everyone here has
run into, is that using the
API at scale has its
challenges.
Specifically on rate limiting.
We got a lot of questions
about that.
But additionally, there's just
some backend limitations and
errors you'll run into, like
concurrent modification, that
is kind of out of
your control.
Something happened at our end,
we couldn't complete that
request, you'd have
to try again.
It becomes frustrating sometimes
to deal with all
these little edge cases.
So a little bit of background.
The BulkMutateJobService was
launched in v2000909, and it
kind of implemented
these ideas.
It allowed for asynchronous
processing in jobs, and it
also had a limited form of
partial failure support, which
meant that it wasn't like if
there was one bad operation in
that job, of a few thousand
operations, that the whole
thing would fail.
So far we've seen some limited
adoption from the community,
as hands here have shown, from
the BulkMutateJobService.
And part of is just it's pretty
complicated to use.
So with v201109, we've
launched this new
MutateJobService.
It reuses the same exact backend
on our side as the
BMJS, so it has a lot of the
same behaviors and a lot of
the same benefits.
But we've simplified the
interface of the API
significantly.
So you now just have three
methods that do everything.
And it supports the same
operations that the
BulkMutateJobService did.
Campaigns, ad groups, ad
criteria, targets, and
extensions.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE] example
code, this is some PHP code.
But to start, I've just
created an array of
operations.
Your application would be
somehow creating work that
needs to be done against
the API.
So once you have that list of
operations, as I mentioned,
you just call the mutate method
asking for that list of
operations.
There's no extra mapping
that needs to go on.
And the next step is just
waiting for that
job to finish now.
So you create a selector using
the job ID that you got back,
and you call it "mutate." And
then in some sort of a loop--
we recommend maybe
30 seconds--
just call using that selector to
find out what the status of
the job is.
And then once you found that the
job is completed, you can
retrieve results using get
result, [? asking ?] that same
selector that specifies
the job ID.
And then it's just a matter of
handling the results and the
errors that are returned.
So the error handling here,
we've tried to make it more
similar to partial failure.
So you get your results back,
and they're the exact same
order as the operations
that you sent in.
But in places where there was a
failure, you're going to get
back a placeholder object,
which has no data.
All of the errors for the entire
job are then included
in a separate array also
in the response.
And you have to use the field
path of the errors to
correlate which operation
caused that error.
To kind of show you what this
looks like graphically, here
we made a very small job of only
three operations, passing
in some key words.
And you can see that the second
keyword there, cat food
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], that failed
because you can't use an
exclamation point
in the keyword.
So you'll see that the results
that came back, we got one
actual AdGroupCriterion for the
top, then a placeholder,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and then the third one is
another AdGroupCriterion.
And then the field
path of the error
references operation one.
So that's how you can kind
of tie this together.
There are some other errors
that are caused by
BulkMutateJob processing
itself.
So lost result is the case where
we know we applied that
operation, but something went
wrong and we don't know what
the result was.
Then there's unprocessed result,
which means that due
some other failure in
the job, we never
even got to this operation.
We didn't even try
to apply it.
And then there's still
this batch failure.
And so what that means is you're
passing a few thousand
operations.
We're going to split that up
into batches, and then if the
type of operation that's in
that batch doesn't support
partial failure, then that
whole batch will fail.
And you'll get a real error
for the operation that
actually had the error, or
if there were multiples.
And then you'll get this batch
failure error for every other
operation in that batch,
that in itself was OK.
It didn't return an error on
its own, but it also didn't
get applied.
So for people who have used the
old BMJS, there are some
differences here you
probably have seen.
The key one I mentioned before
is just simpler jobs.
No parts or streams or other
wrapper objects.
The other difference here is
because this implementation
relies on just one job is
created by the one mutate
request, there is now an upper
limit that's a bit smaller
than the old
BulkMutateJobService for how
many operations can
fit into a job.
Specifically, 10,000.
Now this is much smaller than
the BulkMutateJobService,
which I believe was 500,000.
But the difference here is that
we've now changed the job
infrastructure so that
you can have an
unlimited number of jobs.
You don't need to worry about
filling up a job queue like
there was before.
So what we say is use smaller
jobs and use more of them.
There is some overlap, too,
between these two services.
If you look at the API
documentation very closely,
you'll actually see a lot of
the objects have the word
"BulkMutate" in them, even
though they're part of the new
MutateJobService.
Like I said, because they each
share a lot of the same
backend, they're also sharing
some of the same API
components.
The other thing is, because they
share the same backend,
you can kind of access
either type of
job for either service.
We generally recommend
don't do this.
Stick with one service
and process
everything through there.
Because things can get a bit
complicated when you're using
two different APIs against
different types of data.
So, the benefits.
As the same thing with the
BulkMutateJobService, we
reduced the API unit cost for
using this service, which can
be important to some
customers.
And currently, it's by 50%.
So all operations
cost 50% less.
And then a really big thing that
I think is huge is that
things like rate limiting and
transient failures are
automatically handled by us.
So you will submit a job, and
it doesn't matter if there's
concurrent modification
errors.
You don't need to worry about,
well, am I having too many
threads, or am I sending my
operations too quickly, or
what do I do with
rate limiting?
We take care of all that.
So I think that greatly
simplifies the back and forth
with our servers.
And so, what do we recommend
people use this for?
I'd say the main thing is
time-insensitive work.
You're doing a bulk upload of
a new account, you're doing
some nightly changes to bids.
These are things that they need
to get done, but they
don't need to get done
that instant.
A user in a UI who's trying to
add a campaign, that user
doesn't want to sit around
waiting for a job to finish.
They just want that campaign
created right then so they
could keep working in the UI.
So we do recommend for
time-insensitive work, it's
really where we think the sweet
spot is for these kind
of services.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]